[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته كيفكم
بعد الفسحه ا معليش انا جايه طالبه في
المرحله الثانويه واحنا في المدرسه ما
عندنا الا فسحه وصرفه اوكي اعرفكم بنفسي
انا رغد عبد الله الحربي طالبه في المرحله
الثانويه عمري 18 سنه اؤمن ان الانسان
شكرا اؤمن ان الانسان خلق للانجاز ووهب
بذور العظمه ما اعرف متى بدات رحلتي مع
الانجاز ومتى عرفت اصلا ايش يعني انجاز
لكن افتكر انه انا صغيره كنت انسانه جدا
منجزه يعني لو ماما قالت اليوم حنظ انا
مره افرح عشاني
سرعه توقعوا ايو ولا لا عشان
سنعه لا
لا عشان انا مو كذا عشان ابى اجمع اكبر
قدر ممكن من الحاجات اللي ما منها فايده
عشان كده كانوا في البيت
يسموني ام
قمام ا تعرفوا اي يعني قمام ولا لا يا اهل
الرياض
تعرفوا قمام يعني حاجات ما منها
فائده فتخيلوا انه انا كنت مسويه درج كامل
واجمع فيله قوائمي اضرب لكم مثال هذا ايش
اللي قدام هذا
ايش شوفوا منديل متخيلين انه انا بهذا
المنديل صممت فستان لعروستي واو عشان ايه
عشان ان كنت انظر للاشياء بنظره مختلفه
الشيء اللي ما منه فائده عند رغد ترى له
فائده كذا كان نظامي ماما حرام لا ترميها
اناو حاجه والله انا اقدر اسوي اي شيء
فكانت يعني مديتني على قد جو الله يحفظها
لي وكل مره تخليني اخذها واجمع قوايم بقدر
يعني ما ابى كبرت انتهيت من المرحله
الابتدائيه دخلت المتوسط كبرت بمعنى
الكلمه سمعت قالوا انه فلانه مخترعه وفلان
مخترع رحت لابله العلوم بكل حماس ابل عبير
انا ابى اسوي اختراع قالت سوي
اختراع
وانهت حرفيا انتهى في اول متوسط بهذه
الطريقه يعني قالت سوي اختراع وسويت ما
سويت شيء
عفوا جيت ثاني ثانوي جاتني ابل نجلاء
الغامدي قالت يا رغد انا شفتك شاركتي في
الاولمبياد الوطني للناشئين في كل من
العلوم والرياضيات كنت مبدعه ايش رايك
تشارك في الاولمبياد الوطني للابداع
العلمي ابداع وهنا جت ابلى نجلاء ايقظت
العبقري اللي بداخلي صف قبنا نجدا
الغامدي شاركت في ابداع 2013 بس تتوقعوا
كذا يعني على طول لا اللي حصل انه كانت
ابل الجدا تقول لي شاركي واقول لها ابى
اشارك ابتكار تقول لي لا تشاركي بحث علمي
يا ابله انا ما اعرف ايش يعني بحث علمي
قالت شركي بحث علمي فلما رجعت البيت اقول
لماما وانا اسجل ماما جارك بحث علمي ولا
ابتكار انا ابى ابتكار تقوللي سوي زي ما
قالت الابله شاركت في البحث العلمي انا
الان في علاقه غراميه مع البحث العلمي خمس
سنوات وزي ما اسم رغد مرتبط باسم عبد الله
رغد عبد الله رغد بحث علمي رغد بحث
علمي شاركت في اولمبياد ابداع
2014 ودخلت على المرحله الثانويه وطورت من
نفسي كل مرحله سبحان الله الواحد يتغير و
يتطور قلت هذه السنه هشارك في مسار
الابتكار حسوي ابتكار بديت بكل ما اوتيته
من حماس او اسوي اسوره تساعد الصو
المكفوفين كيف وقت الحريق لانه الاجهزه
المتوفره ما تخدمهم بالطريقه الصحيحه
فقررت انه ا على هذا المشروع مره على مره
وتطوير على تطوير فحنا عندنا طريقتين اول
شيء نبدا بالاختراع مرحله توليد الفكره ثم
نبتكر يعني نحول هذه الفكره الى ايه الى
منتج
محسوس
فمرحى كانت صعبه بس جدا ممتعه ما خليت احد
مكتوب عند اسمه مهندس الا وسالته اذا كان
في مه مهندس يعني يعرفني وسالته فشكرا لكم
من كل اعماق قلبي على صبركم
ا في 2015 لما شاركت وانتهيت من مرحله
الاختراع اسوره تساعد الصو المكفوفين
تحتوي على ثلاث خواص كل خاصيه تخدمهم
وتحقق هدف
معين كانت الفكره انه انا حسوي الاسور
بهذا الشكل واو باختصار واو انا رهيبه
حسوي الاوره زي كذا يعني باختصار افتح
جوجل واتخيل
اسورتي ترى انا اليوم جيت معاي اختراعي
الاسوره حقتي بس انا ما حطلع الا لما
تقولوا واحد انين 3 بصوت عالي بصوت عالي
اوكي يلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ابداوا رغد انت من اول تقولي اسوره
بس انا ماني شايفه اي اسوره هذا بالضبط
اللي قالت لي اياه محكمه اولمبياد ابداع
2015 كان ردي مسكت كذا الاسوره بيد الجهاز
حقي عفوا هو مو اسوره بس جهاز فعليا يحقق
نفس الاهداف يعني لو انتم حابين
تسمعوا نفس اللي تخيلته بس اللهم انه شكله
مو اسور يعني اختلاف
بسيط اللي حصل انه لما قالتلي زي كذا مسكت
جوالي بكف قت شايف هذا الجوال قديش كفاءته
عاليه انت متخيله انه قبل كم سنه كان في
جهاز اقل منه كفاءه وهو بح اجمل غرفه حتى
ابتكاري قابل للتغيير قابل للتطوير ممكن
يصير خاتم تلبسيه في
يدك ايش كان ردها رقد انت اقنعتني وديتك
الدرجه كامله واو الحمد
لله تتوقع اهدت
لوين لو في احد من ابداع يعرفه وصلت لنصف
النهائيات وانتهت رحلتي مع ابداع لكن انا
مستمره في الانجاز عرضت مشروعي على عدد من
الشركات استقبلتني احد الشركات قالوا لي
انت فكرتك حلوه انت ذكيه لكن ترى فكرتك
غير
مربحه انتهى لا ما انتهى طبعا قلت لهم طب
ممكن اطور فكرتي اجيكم اخليها مربحه قالوا
بسم الله يعني شكرا لهذه الشركه صراحه انه
دعموني بديت افكر افكر كيف اخليها مربحه
واش الخلل اللي موجود فيها كان الخلل انه
هي تخدم فئه قليله من المجتمع فما حتكون
مربحه فايش سويت وسعه الابتكار خليته يخدم
جميع فئات المجتمع تحول من امبره اللي
المفروض يكون شكله اسوره ومو اسوره كشاف
فعليا هو كشاف وبالشكل اللي انا
اتخيله الحمد
[تصفيق]
لله طبعا بهذا الاختراع ما حققت ولا
ميداليه حرفيا ولا حققت اي
مركز بالرغم من تحقيقي على ميداليات في
بحوث اخرى واختراعات لكن تعمدت انه انا
اليوم اتكلم عن الاختراع اللي ما حققت فيه
ولا حاجه
ليش ترى مو بس هذا في كثير غيره ما حققت
فيهم ولا شيء ليش تكلمت عن هذا بالذات
عشان اثبت لكم انه الانجاز هو الاعظم ايش
هذه حديده ايش هذه خيوط تديني قيبه ولا
هذا الشيء اللي انا تعبته هو القيمه
الحقيقيه ايها
المبدعون ايها المبدعون انتم من تختارون
الانجاز وشخص اخر على حسب رايه حختار انت
تستحق الذهبيه ولا فضيه ولا حتى ما تستحق
شيء من حقكم تفتخرون باي انجاز الانجاز
اللي انتم حققتو وميداليه اللي لبسكم شخص
اخر فيه هذه الميداليه لبسكم اياها وقال
انت رائعون لا انا الرائع لاني انا قررت
انجز بينما غيري مرتاح انا رائع انا مميز
رددوا هذه العبارات لانفسكم
دائما هنا في تدكس الرياض
نب ننقذ كل ما فينا من حماس من ابداع من
شجاعه انا ناديتكم بالمبدعين لاني متاكده
انه كل شخص فينا عنده شي وبدع فيه قد
ضحكوا عليك الناس قد قالوا انت سخيف واشك
ما منها فايده يوم من الايام لو انت فعلا
تؤمن بالحلم والشيء اللي انت تسويه
هتخليهم يجلسوا ويصفق لك يقولوا واو انت
سويت حاجه رهيبه اذا انت امنت بحلمك عمره
ما في احد حيوقف لو كل الناس قالوا رغد ام
قمام ترا صارت مخترعه رغده اللي ما
كانت ترى موضوع ما كان يعني هم بقولوا خمس
سنوات كثيره بس انا اشوف الخمس سنوات مرت
باعظم تجارب خمس سنوات اربع فشل وفي
الخامسه نجحت اربع سنوات من اجمل سنين
عمري وكل سنه اتعلم حاجه لما الناس
يشوفوني فاشه انا اشوف اني تعلمت اكتسبت
حاجه جديده انظروا دائما
للزوايا الرائعه من اي شيء في حياتكم حتى
كانت بنت اختي تقول لي رغد انت ليه دائما
كده يعني انا طلل في المض الموضوع شي وانت
تطلي فيه شيء ثاني اديني شويه من ايجابيتك
ا الحين ابى كل واحد فيكم اللي افتكر ان
هو انجز او حقق اي شيء و ما ادوه ميداليه
او هذه ميداليه ما ادوه ميداليه وقالوا
قال عن نفسه انه مو رائع ولا ما ادوه مركز
وقال ان هو ما سوى شيء حلو ا الحين
يوقف يصفق لنفسه اكبر تحيه في الحياه
ويقول قوم يا حلمي قوم انا حساعدك تتحقق
حقف يوم حخلي كل الناس اللي ضحكوا علي يصف
قي ممكن المحكم اللي ما اداني الميداليه
يكون اول شخص منتفع بعملي تحيه
لانفسكم اي قضوا احلامكم ايقظوا ما
بداخلكم من ابداع تذكروني دائما رقد عبد
الله مع
[تصفيق]
السلامه